foreign
my wife and me have been married for 17
years
we've got four kids
they brought our home nine years ago in
Granger Indiana
right well
the septic should never have been passed
okay
on the inspection
yeah all right my brother-in-law is a
septic Guru that's what he does he works
for safe septic and let's throw a plug
out there
um
it should never passed
but it happens he says it happens all
the time they pass it
for about a year however either way that
that ship is sailed we try to contact uh
uh health inspector we had six months
and you know had I known then I'm 40
years old had I known men what I know
now I've done a little more digging
Okay so we've it's done the subject is
done 100 percent
all right uh what's it gonna cost to get
a new septic system 50 to 60.
it's going to be about 30 probably 25 30
000 okay that's nice all right okay but
that's a deep cut that's taking six feet
of Earth the entire length of my field
system out with x amount of dump trucks
and bringing that same amount back with
gravel sand blah blah that's right and
you got to collapse the other system at
the at the front yeah
there's an option of putting it in my
front yard which is my baby I mean I've
worked hard
so what's your question my baby yeah so
what's up so my question is don't take
out a loan to do this is that if that's
what you're gonna ask that's my question
I think should I reach should
I'm Telling You Should I refinance
my home which makes no sense I'm at a
four I'm unlocked in at four we bought
it years ago
it makes no sense for a whole lot of
reasons the interest rate is just one of
the smaller ones for me they're stupid
right now so yeah Democrats I mean I get
it but yeah I I can
like a HELOC if I did a HELOC because I
don't have that cash on hand we've been
throwing so much money at the house how
much money do you have right now
yes
yeah I mean liquid cash to your name
things you could sell whatever
uh
eleven thousand dollars okay do you have
any other debt other than the mortgage
no sir well we have we have my my truck
I only owe four thousand on that I
bought it two and a half years ago we've
been triple payment what would the truck
sell for today
oh sh probably 25 000.
ta-da now you can go to the bathroom in
peace
I know Josh I love my truck like we
worked so I've been blessed I know but
you love your grass and your truck and
pretty soon You're Gonna Love not going
to the bathroom indoors
I know man you love your family more
than you love the truck I've got a
promotion at work I'm making excellent
how much you make what's your salary
well for this
yeah I make 115 000 a Year Josh hey if
you ever hang your head on 115 Grand
I am blessed the Lord has
to me Joshua can the septic system wait
two months
that's my question too okay
you're a financial math guy okay I'm
good at math but okay let's say
if if if my my brother-in-law can pump
my septic I basically have an 1100
gallon tank in my backyard that's it
with no function so two months it's full
so if I did two months at 260 a pump
that's 130 a month
if I just wrote that out for a couple
years and just started stacking cash
away when that couple of years dude I'm
talking about having this thing paid for
in cash within a few months which means
you're living off of nothing we're
selling everything that's not tied down
and we're getting done with this but but
isn't but that's my question does it
make more sense to just pinch it maybe
pinch it no here's what that's a funny
thing that you said referring to your
septic system number one you get by with
what you can do until you have the cash
to pay for it in full that's it I would
pump it for two months a maximum of
three
and I would take that 11 Grand and we
would stop paying 50 uh 50x on my truck
stop paying extra on the mortgage stop
going out to eat for three months and I
would scrounge together another 10 grand
which you can do on your salary
we're putting together here okay I
worked in the RV business okay
okay it's a very bad time to be in
manufacturing because of the Democrats
okay it's very very listen Joshua how
long are we going to blame the Democrats
for a freaking septic system oh well I
am always going to right
blaming listen to me you sell the truck
for 25 you owe four on it correct
that's 21k you get a beater truck and
with the rest you add to your 11k you
have a new septic system next week and
then you save up for the next three to
five months and buy yourself another
truck ta-da you can poop the Democrats
have nothing to do with this
look in the mirror Joshua who didn't
walk into the septic system issue listen
I have a potential two months
that's actually Fair that's fair I'll
give you that I'll give you no order so
then what do I do if I spend my eleven
thousand dollars to my name
okay but brother listen if that two
months turns into five and you've put
your house on the Block for a septic
tank they're gonna take everything
true okay I I don't do very very good
okay I got okay now I think you are
right to be worried I am worried because
I don't know what my next it's great but
hold on listen listen to fall out in any
second what I know but what you're doing
is very common I've done it too when I
get anxious about one thing I put all my
energy and start making wild decisions
about other things
okay the thing I can't control in my
life it scares me I just start running
and trying to find other things I can
control I can sign up for this I can get
this I can double down on this I can
move this dead over here to this thing
and I create a chaotic mess and
interestingly I make my anxiety
infinitely worse
if I'm you and I'm staring at a 60-day
I'm making no dollars
my life is shutting down financially
potentially 250 days I mean it could be
sure so here's what I'm doing and then
I'm getting a job tomorrow
and you work too hard I work I'm a hard
worker but yeah I know you understand I
mean the RV industry the industry is
completely done right now okay then get
out of that industry
if Dave came in here and said hey we're
not getting any more radio ads y'all are
gonna get paid for the next two to six
months I wouldn't work here man I'd be
at the Apple Store
you know around here it's 17 an hour
somewhere you know what I mean like you
know what it is you know what that's 17
an hour more than you're gonna make
yeah yeah I know listen here's the deal
here's what I know for certain the data
tells me that job loss
the body experience is job loss the same
as losing a loved one
and I want you to reckon with the fear
and being scared
and then I want you to remember this
phrase facts are your friends
I will not put my house on the Block for
what might be a six-month issue I won't
I won't put my family in that kind of in
that kind of disorder I'll go work a job
that is way beneath what I think I'm
worth
because I'm that kind of guy well I tell
my kids that I know let them hey don't
tell them anything let them watch it I
Shield I Shield them from all the
scariness of my industry right don't
don't Shield them sit them down and say
things are really scary so dad's gonna
have to do some different stuff don't
Shield them don't lie to them show them
things got really scary and here's what
I'm gonna do next that's a gift